it's possible that
that like an alien species will have uh
depending on different cognitive
capabilities and
different perception systems we'll be
able to see
things that are much different than
circles and so
if it's discovered it would still be
pointing at a lot of same geometrical
concepts
mathematical concepts but
it's interesting to think of how many
things we would have to still
align not just based on notation but
based on understanding like
just the like um some basic mathematical
concepts
like how much work is there going to be
in trying to find a common language
i mean this is um i think stephen
wolfram and his son help with the movie
arrival
like the developing an alien language
like how would aliens communicate with
humans
it's fascinating because like math seems
to be the most promising thing but even
like math
like how do you visualize
mathematical ideas it feels like there
has to be an
interactive component just like we have
a conversation there has to be this is
something we don't
i think think about often which is like
with somebody who doesn't know anything
about math doesn't know
anything about english or any other
natural language how would we describe
we talked offline about visual proofs
how would we
through visual proofs have a
conversation
where we say something here's the
concept the way we see it
does that make sense to you and like can
you mess with that concept
to make it sense for you and then go
back and forth in this kind of way
so purely through mathematics i'm sure
it's possible to have those kind of
experiments with like tribes on earth
that don't
there's no common language through math
like draw a circle
and see what they do with it right do
some of these visual proofs
uh like the summation of the odds and
the adds up to the squares
yes i wonder how difficult that is uh
before one one or the other species
murders
i i hope that the curiosity for
knowledge will overpower the greedy
this is back to our game theory thing
that the curiosity of like
discovering math together will overpower
the desire for resources
and uh ultimately like you know
willing to commit violence in order to
gain those resources
i think as we progress become more and
more intelligent as a species i'm hoping
we would value more and more the
knowledge because we'll come up with
clever ways to gain more resources so we
won't be so resource starved
i don't know that's a hopeful message
from when we finally meet aliens
yeah yeah
you